foreign
I had lots of friends in undergrad who
were thinking about it or had applied or
even gone to business school through
through deferred enrollment programs and
from everything they had told me it
sounded like and during the real world
after undergrad with a golden ticket to
be able to take a risk and do something
that you really feel passionate about
during the time between undergrad and
business school rather than just
following a traditional or prescribed
path and so that was something that was
always really appealing to me and that I
was excited to learn more about
I always knew I wanted to end up in the
healthcare space and early on in my life
I thought that meant going to medical
school and becoming a doctor and then
during my undergrad I shifted and
decided I wanted to do something at the
intersection of business and medicine
and so I accepted a role to join Morgan
Stanley full-time after after college to
get some hard finance and business
skills and I thought deferred enrollment
would be the perfect opportunity to
bridge my experiences and pivot away
from traditional Finance into something
more entrepreneurial in the healthcare
space
after graduating from undergrad I joined
Morgan Stanley in their Investment
Banking program and while I was there I
met the founders of a series a fertility
technology startup and they asked me to
come join them and help them build the
team and launch the product and run
their Finance function for them and I
ended up taking the leap and leaving
Morgan Stanley and joining that company
called tomorrow life sciences and was
there for two and a half years we grew
from fewer than 10 employees to over a
hundred we closed our series C and
launched our product right before I left
to come to to the GSB and I really think
that I I would not have had the courage
or the guts to make that change and and
pivot away from the path that I was on
had it not been for deferred enrollment
[Music]
well it takes me all the way back to
high school when I came and visited for
undergrad and really fell in love with
the campus and you know everything about
the school so I've been dreaming of it
for a long time at that time I thought
it would be maybe for medical school but
then shifted shifted into the the
business path and it's been everything
that I dreamed of since then and more
um you know just coming from the east
coast and getting to experience the West
Coast way of life the weather the
environment you know I wake up and open
my shades and it's palm trees Blue Sky
people biking and running past past my
window so it's really it's like paradise
in so many ways and then I think back to
when I wrote my deferred enrollment
application I was a senior at Yale and I
wrote about so many things including the
biodesign Innovation program the
healthcare club and now I'm taking the
biodesign Innovation course which has
been incredible
foreign
GSB plans I I do not know I'm only in my
my first year which is coming to a close
which is crazy uh this summer I'll be
working or interning at Maverick
ventures in San Francisco and then at a
healthcare startup which is one of their
portfolio companies in London for a few
weeks so I'm really excited for that
I've never worked in VC before so I'm
looking forward to to having that
experience this summer and and then also
the the healthcare startup experience
and just keeping you know my my eyes
open and and learning a lot from the
people that I'll be working with and
then we'll see see where next year takes
me
foreign